Das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Ich möchte mich beim SPIEGEL, bei Klaus Brinkbäumer, bei Alfred Weinzill, aber insbesondere bei meinem damaligen Ressortleiter Michael Wulzinger dafür bedanken, dass sie mir für diese Arbeit mit dem Whistleblower so vertraut haben. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, da geht ein durchgeknallter Reporter in das Ressortleiterzimmer und sagt, ich möchte jetzt nach Osteuropa fliegen. Ich kann dir nicht sagen, wohin. Ich kann dir nicht sagen, wann ich wiederkomme. Ich weiß nicht, ob auch nur eine einzige Zeile davon am Ende in unserem Blatt erscheint. Und übrigens, die Chefredaktion darf nicht wissen, wo ich hinfliege, weil das habe ich dem Whistleblower versprochen. Es darf in keiner Reiseabrechnung vorkommen. Und dann ein Nicken zu bekommen und vorm Ressortleiter gesagt zu bekommen, pass auf dich auf, ruf an, komm wieder.
Ich möchte mich dafür einfach bedanken. So fing es alles an mit einem Nicken, mit einem Macht's gut und Komm gut wieder. Wir hörten den Journalisten Rafael Buschmann vom SPIEGEL, Autor des kürzlich oder ganz neu erschienen Buches Football Leaks. Und das Zitat entstammt seiner Dankesrede bei der Wahl zum Sportjournalist des Jahres. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass ich ihn hier im Rasenfunk im Tribünengespräch der Ausgabe Nummer 10 zu den Football Leaks begrüßen kann. Schön, dass du mit dabei bist, Rafael. Wir wollen heute über die Football Leaks sprechen, aber nicht zu zweit, sondern wir haben auch noch Nicole Selmer mit dabei, stellvertretende Chefredakteurin vom österreichischen Fußballmagazin Ballesterer mit ihrer Rasenfunk-Premiere. Nicole, ich freue mich sehr, dass du auch Zeit dafür hattest.
Ich freue mich auch sehr.
Wir reden über einen komplexen Sachverhalt, über die Football Leaks. Der eine oder andere Hörer wird schon davon gehört haben, denn es ging – man kam eigentlich als Fußballfans nicht an diesem Thema vorbei – im Dezember 2016. Es gibt dazu bereits auch schon einen Kurzpass mit Christophs Hendrichs. Ich werde den in den Show Notes nochmal verlinken. Aber anlässlich des jetzt jüngst erschienenen Buches von Rafael Buschmann und Michael Wulzinger wollte ich dieses Thema noch etwas ausführlicher besprechen. Das Buch ist erschienen, damit das einmal gesagt wurde, in der Verlagsgruppe Random House heißt Football Leaks. Ihr werdet wahrscheinlich nicht dran vorbeikommen und es ist sehr empfehlenswert. Aber um gleich ins Thema einzusteigen, Rafael, kannst du uns nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, was sind denn die Football Leaks?
Die Football Leaks sind ein Datenpaket von 18, 6 Millionen Dokumenten, 1, 9 Terabyte, das der Spiegel vor jetzt fast eineinhalb Jahren bzw. im Februar 2016 von einem Whistleblower namens John erhalten hat. John ist derjenige, der als Gesicht für die Plattform Football Leaks auftritt, das ist eine Enthüllungsplattform im Internet, die sich damit beschäftigt, die Schattenseiten des Fußballs, das Enthämmtsein einer Branche, die finanzielle Überhöhung dieses Geschäftsbereiches zu skizzieren, zu offenbaren, zu enthüllen. Er hat das, bzw. Football Leaks hat das zunächst einmal seit Ende September 2015 über ihre Website gemacht und dann ab Mai 2016 sich zurückgezogen, sodass der Spiegel in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Recherchennetzwerk European Investigative Collaborations, dem EIC, gemeinsam diese 18, 6 Millionen Dokumente sieben Monate lang ausgewertet hat. Unser Team bestand auf 60 Journalisten, mehr als 100 Personen waren insgesamt daran beteiligt, weil auch noch Fact-Checker, IT-Gurus wie unser Stefan Hefner, der hier für den Spiegel das gemacht hat, daran beteiligt waren Layoutern und in dem Zuge haben wir im vergangenen Dezember über 400 Artikel zu den Football Leaks europaweit veröffentlicht.
Wir bewegen uns heute in einem Thema der großen Zahlen und das fängt schon hier an, 400 Artikel, 1, 9 Terabyte, 16 Millionen Dokumente. Das durchzieht auch das ganze Thema Football Leaks, aber noch aus anderen Gründen, die großen Zahlen. Aber was sind denn das eigentlich für Dokumente?
Wir haben im Prinzip in diesem Datenschatz alles, von der SMS bis zum unterschriebenen Vertrag, bis zu Nebenabsprachen, Verträgen, die nur zwischen Spielern und Investoren getroffen wurden. Wir haben E-Mails, wir haben Kontoauszüge, wir haben Geldflüsse. Also es ist ein riesiges Konvolut. Man kann es nicht auf ein oder zwei Dateinamen oder Formate runter reduzieren. Auch die Personen, die es geht, die Vereine, die es geht, sind völlig heterogen. Es ist ganz schwierig, nur auf einen Bereich zu reduzieren. Es ist ein riesiges Sammelsorium aus dem Innersten des Fußballs.
Woher bekommt man denn SMS zum Beispiel? Also woher kommen denn diese Daten? Das ist ja – und auch Kontoauszüge, das liegt ja nirgendwo rum.
Also ich habe versucht, dem auf die Spur zu gehen, habe jetzt seit deutlich über einem Jahr Kontakt zu dem Whistleblower. Die Frage ist eine der Fragen, die ich immer wieder gestellt habe, da auch zwischenzeitlich der Vorwurf aufkam, dass er möglicherweise ein Hacker ist oder dass Football Leaks eine Hacker-Organisation ist. Das hat er immer verneint. Er hat immer gesagt, dass das nicht stimmen würde, dass sie sehr gute Quellen haben, die sie mit Dokumenten beliefern. Schwierig zu sagen, bis heute habe ich darauf keine Lösung. Sie kommen so an das Material, wie WikiLeaks an das Material kommt, die von sich auch behaupten, sie seien keine Hacker und denen das Material zugespielt werden würde. Ob das stimmt oder nicht, möchte ich keinen Urteil zu abgeben, weil ich keine belegbaren Beweise für das eine oder für das andere habe.
Über eure Beweggründe dennoch mit dem Material zu arbeiten. Ich habe dir in euren Artikeln schon geschrieben und auch im Buch kann man das nochmal ganz gut nachlesen. Ich möchte jetzt aber die Meinung von Nicole dazu interessieren. Findest du, man sollte mit so sensiblen Daten wie SMS und Kontouszügen arbeiten?
Gute Frage. Ich habe da jetzt eben auch nochmal darüber nachgedacht, als du das jetzt so nochmal ausgebreitet hast. Das, glaube ich, ist tatsächlich auch ganz viel eine datenrechtliche, juristische Einschätzung letztlich. Die ihr beim SPIEGEL, nehme ich mal an, Rafael, da werdet ihr ja ausführlich darüber gesprochen haben.
Um da nur eine ganz kurze Klammer reinzumachen, ich habe unsere Anwälte in den vergangenen zwölf Monaten häufiger gesehen als meine Ehefrau.
Das tut mir für beide leid, für die Anwälte und für die Ehefrau.
Ich glaube, dass das die eine Antwort auf die Frage ist, wo man sich auch einfach absichern muss, und das andere ist dann natürlich zu fragen, woher kommen diese Daten, wer können wir dem auch vertrauen, weil das habt ihr ja auch dann zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt entschieden oder euch auch das ist ja, also ich hab das Buch jetzt, das habe ich im Vorgespräch schon kurz gesagt, ich habe es jetzt noch, ich habe es so ein bisschen drinnen gelesen, weil ich es jetzt wirklich heute erst bekommen habe, das ist ja dann auch immer mal wieder Thema, dass es dann auch Zweifel gibt an dem John und ich glaube, dass das tatsächlich sicherlich auch ein Prozess ist, der die ganze Zeit weiterläuft.
Genau, also für uns sind am Ende ja zwei Faktoren entscheidend gewesen, dass die Dokumente authentisch sind, dass sie echt sind und dass sie relevant sind. Also ich glaube, wären wir ein Boulevard-Medium, dann hätte es ein ziemlich unangenehmes Feuerwerk für die Fußballbranche gegeben, weil natürlich da auch sehr, sehr sensible Daten über, keine Ahnung, Frauengeschichten drinstehen, über Zeugs, was wahnsinnig tief in die Privatsphäre eindringt. Das aber eigentlich de facto nichts mit dem Fokus zu tun hat, auf den wir schauen, also die geschäftlichen Praktiken im Fußball, die strafrechtlichen Praktiken im Fußball, die Beschreibung der Hemmungslosigkeit einer Branche. Das war für uns der Fokus. Anhand dieser Schwelle haben wir an zwei Faktoren versucht, immer wieder zu bemessen. Das eine war die Authentizität der Daten, die für uns nach anfänglichen – also es hat sicherlich vier Monate gedauert, bis wir uns sicher waren, dass wir da mit echtem Material arbeiten, weil wir das von unterschiedlichen Seiten abgeklopft haben. Aber der zweite Faktor war, dass wir immer gesagt haben, wir brauchen eine Relevanz. Für uns muss es eine gesellschaftliche Relevanz geben, warum wir über diese Themen schreiben. Wenn eine SMS zwar total interessant war und möglicherweise auch für uns überrascht hat oder uns neugierig gemacht hat, aber für die Gesellschaft keine Relevanz hatte, sondern nur ein Beurismus war oder eine Schlüssellochguckerei, haben wir uns durchweg dagegen entschieden, darüber zu schreiben.
Also ich finde, das merkt man auch bei den Sachen, die ich gelesen habe, dass ihr diese Versuchung, den Boulevard-Themen aufzusitzen, den, der ja auch nicht erliegt, würde ich sagen. Ich meine, was mich damals bei den Artikeln, also gerade auch bei der Präsentation dann beim SPIEGEL, also hier in Österreich beim Falter, lief, das würde ich sagen, auch noch mal ein bisschen anders. Klar, weil der SPIEGEL ja auch so ein bisschen, also einfach das Flaggschiff des Netzwerks war, also dieses mit diesen großen, mit den Superlative zu kommen, eben die größte Datenmenge und das größte Leak, das größte, und dass ich da so ein bisschen den Eindruck hatte, dass dahinter, also dahinter diesem, diesem, diesem ganz großen Tamtam dieses, aber worum, worum geht es eigentlich, dass das da so ein bisschen unterging. Und ich habe jetzt eben auch noch mal gedacht, dass ein Problem dieser eben dieser Datenmenge und dieser, dieser vor allem dieser großen Heterogenität, also das ist einfach hier auch total nicht nur unterschiedliche Datensorten, sondern einfach auch total unterschiedliche Themen. Also es ist was ganz anderes, ob ich jetzt über was macht ein Spielerberater, was für verrückte Einzelheiten stehen in irgendwelchen Verträgen, wie geht ein Spieler mit seinen Steuern um, wie werden die Bildrechte irgendwie anders steuerlich abgesetzt. Also das ist irgendwie alles geschäftlich, aber es sind trotzdem, es sind trotzdem ja sehr unterschiedliche Themen. Und da hatte ich jetzt gerade bei dem Start im letzten Jahr den Eindruck, dass das so in diesem großen – wow, aber jetzt – das größte, so und so viel Terabyte, dass das so ein bisschen runtergegangen ist und dann irgendwie manchmal so ein bisschen, ja ja, sind eh alle korrupt oder sind irgendwie scheiß Millionäre oder der Fußball ist verdorben, das wissen wir ja aber eh, was ja auch gar keine hilfreiche Reaktion ist. Und ja auch gar keine, die man erreichen will.
Ich habe damals einen Kommentar gelesen, der direkt nach dem ersten Titelstück zu Ronaldo beziehungsweise Özil erschienen ist. Ich freue mich über Kritik, ich freue mich über konstruktive Kritik und habe mich versucht damit auseinanderzusetzen. Ich glaube, du hast an einem Punkt recht. Ich glaube, wir hätten noch stärker darauf eingehen müssen, dass wir eine Serie machen. Also, dass es nicht nur um Image Rights geht und nicht nur um steuerliche Angelegenheit geht, sondern dass wir versuchen, ein Sittengemälde dieser Branche zu zeichnen. Ich glaube, das hätten wir noch stärker herausheben müssen, weil sonst möglicherweise dieser Eindruck entstanden wäre, wir haben 18, 6 Millionen Dokumente und haben am Ende einen Titel zu Ronaldo beziehungsweise zu Özil daraus gebastelt. Vielleicht ist das so ein bisschen dieses Gap, das daraus entstanden ist. Ganz grundsätzlich bewegen wir uns da ja in einem totalen Spagat. Auf der einen Seite versuchen wir, den Transparenzgedanken oder auch diesen Wunsch nach Transparenz des Lesers zu bedienen, weil Leser von uns wissen wollen, was für Daten das sind, wo die Daten herkommen. Das sind Fragen, die uns eigentlich nahezu erreichen. Das heißt, wir versuchen das auch zu erklären. Es sind 18, 6 Millionen Dokumente, es sind 1, 9 Terabyte. Das ist der Whistleblower, der dahinter steht. Das Problem von solchen Riesenzahlen und möglicherweise auch der Beschreibung, dass es das größte Lack im Sport ist, ist natürlich immer, dass man so ein bisschen abrutscht in zu lautes Getrommel. Auf der anderen Seite weiß ich nicht, wie man so etwas verhindern kann. Das ist das größte Lack im Sport. Was ist, muss man sagen. Es gab noch keinen Datenlack, was größer war als diese 1, 9 Terabyte. Das sind nochmal 18, 6 Millionen Dokumente. Also müssen wir uns versuchen, daran zu orientieren. Ich habe eigentlich die Hoffnung gehabt, dass wir das an vielen Stellen mit einem leisen Ton hinbekommen haben. Aber wenn man gleichzeitig mit 12 Medienhäusern über ganz Europa startet, inklusive der Begleitung von Online, Print und Fernsehen, mag es auch sein, dass das einfach da vielleicht eine Lautstärke auftritt, die auf den einen oder anderen auch so wirkt, als ob es dann in dem Moment zu viel ist. Wenn es so ist, tut mir das leid, weil das niemand hier so gewollt hat. Auf der anderen Seite ist es natürlich hier auch ein Team. Wir sind über 100 Leute, man arbeitet sieben Monate daran und mit Verlaub, man ist auch am Ende stolz, dass man diesen Datenberg in irgendeiner Form bewältigt hat, dass man diese Konstrukte verstanden hat, dass man die Firmen entschlüsseln konnte, dass man sich hier – das waren teilweise auch echt unangenehme Tage, wenn man hier 18, 20 Stunden in diesem Datenraum gehockt hat und versucht hat, sich durch Kontoauszüge zu prügeln und immer wieder festgestellt hat, dass man an einem Strom anlandet oder dass man einen Firmenamen 12 Mal lesen muss, weil die Firma nach einer Geldtransaktion sofort wieder abgewickelt wurde. Wir schlicht und ergreifend fast den Verstand verloren haben, um dem Geld hinterherzukommen. Das dann nach sieben Monaten kurz vor Ende des Jahres – man kommt damit mit diesen Geschichten raus und wer das Buch liest und auch das Ende des Buches liest, wird sehen, unter was für einem Druck wir insbesondere in den letzten drei Tagen gestanden haben. Wir haben damals unsere Konfrontation an die Gegenseite rausgeschickt, wie es manchmal im Fußball ist oder wie der Fußball ist, oft für sich nutzt. Er versucht Informationshochheit zu bewahren und arbeitet dann mit eigenen Abspielkanälen. Wenn wir zwei oder drei Tage vor Veröffentlichungsbeginn hören, dass ein anderes Medium unsere Geschichte machen soll, weil es die Konfrontationsfragen bekommen hat, die sehr detailliert gestellt waren, weil wir natürlich der Gegenseite zu allem eine Antwortmöglichkeit geben müssen, dann ist es einfach auch so, dass wir uns wahnsinnig gefreut haben, dass wir dieses Projekt so trocken durchbekommen haben.
Jetzt sind wir schon in der Diskussion gelandet zur Art der Präsentation und haben so ein bisschen den Inhalt übersprungen. Lasst uns da mal noch zurückgehen. Also, ihr habt diese große Menge an Dokumenten, kann man nur mit technologischen Hilfsmitteln dann scannen. Das sollte jedem klar sein, dass man das nicht alles ausdrucken kann. Wie ihr das gemacht habt, beschreibt ihr im Buch. Und da habe ich auch im Kurzpass mit Christoph Henrichs ein bisschen näher drüber gesprochen. Aber jetzt lass uns doch mal kurz über das sprechen, was ihr jetzt aufgedeckt habt mit den Football Leaks und wahrscheinlich auch noch weitere Dinge aufdecken werdet. Du hast gesagt, es soll ein Sit-In-Gemälde des Fußballs sein. Wie sieht es denn aus, dieses Sit-In-Gemälde?
Um es jetzt in kurzen Worten zu fassen, was schwierig ist bei so einem riesen Projekt und so einem Datenberg, würde ich trotzdem sagen, dass es eine Branche ist, die sich mittlerweile nur noch an einem einzigen Faktor orientiert. Und der Faktor ist Geldmaximierung. Es gibt im Fußball, zumindest auf geschäftlicher Ebene, aus meiner Sicht keinen anderen Anreiz mehr. Es gibt nicht die Befriedung von Fans. Es gibt nicht den reinen sportlichen Wunsch, sondern Fußballvereine sind Unternehmen. Spielerberater drum herum sind profitorientiert. Und diese Branche hat so eine immense Finanzkraft, dass sie auch in der Lage ist, mit all diesen Beratern, Steuerberatern, Spielerberatern, Anwälten um sich herum für Geldflüsse zu sorgen, die für Polizeien, für Staatsanwälte in Europa nicht mehr nachvollziehbar sind. Das Operieren mit Steuerasen, mit Briefkastenfirmen, mit Strohmännern, mit kleinen Privatbanken, die ihre Tore für niemanden öffnen, das gehört mittlerweile komplett zum Fußball dazu. Das ist ein Bestandteil dieser Branche. Ich glaube, dass diese Branche – das sieht man auch an den ganzen Ethikkommissionen, die von Verbänden gegründet werden und an den Integrity-Ob-Männern, die in den Vereinen gegründet werden – diese Branche ist sich selbst total genug. Sie sieht, dass ihr niemand mehr so richtig auf die Finger guckt und sie ist auch von niemanden mehr abhängig. Sie kann, wie gesagt, die Justiz relativ leicht momentan ausdribbeln. Fans sind seit langer Zeit viel zu weit weg von dieser Branche und sie ist eine völlig entfesselte, enthemmte Branche.
Wenn ich jetzt zusammenfassen müsste, was sogegebenermaßen schwierig ist, was so die Kernthemen in den Football Leaks sind, dann tauchen so gewisse Mechaniken immer wieder auf. Da haben sich so gewisse Best-Practice-Beispiele oder Worst-Practice-Beispiele aus moralischer Sicht etabliert, mit denen die beteiligten Akteure es schaffen, noch mehr Geld zu verdienen, das verdiente Geld nicht zu versteuern, generell ihr Kapital zu maximieren. Das werden für mich drei Themen, Gebiete, und da würde ich dich mal bitten, Rafael, dass du uns kurz, soweit es möglich ist, mal erklärst, warum es da eigentlich geht. Das eine sind Offshore-Konten mit Briefkastenfirmen, die vor allem zur Vermeidung von Steuern eingesetzt werden. Was habt ihr da zu rausgefunden?
Das würde ich gerne exemplarisch an einem Beispiel erzählen, aber dieses Beispiel soll nie so verstanden werden, dass es für sich alleine steht. Das ist ein Beispiel, das für die Branche steht. Das ist nur ein besonders dreistes Beispiel. Cristiano Ronaldo, der in seiner damaligen Zeit bei Real Madrid zur aktuellen Zeit rund 38 Millionen Euro verdient als Grundgehalt, benötigt um sich herum zwei weitere Firmen, die für ihn seine weltweiten Werbeerlöse strukturieren, einnehmen, verarbeiten. Die eine der beiden Firmen ist in Irland, die andere der beiden Firmen auf den British Virgin Islands. Beide Länder stehen im Ruf, Steueroasen zu sein. In Irland sind es 12, 5 Prozent, mit denen versteuert wird, auf den British Virgin Islands genau 0 Prozent. Und über diese beiden Firmen schafft es Christiano Ronaldo bzw. seine Berater, diese Werbeerlöse zu verschleiern. Sie verschicken diese Werbeerlöse bis auf die British Virgin Islands. Das ist ein dreistelliger Millionenbetrag, der irgendwann durch eine Firma namens Tollin läuft und nach einer gewissen Zeit auf einer Privatbank in der Schweiz landet. Das Ganze ist am Ende – wir können es doch nicht mal beurteilen, ob es am Ende legal oder illegal ist. Es ist ein Steuerschlupfloch, es ist ein Steueroptimierungsansatz, der dort gewählt wird, den man normalerweise aus der Wirtschaft kennt, also von Großunternehmen wie Apple, Starbucks, Amazon, die so etwas in den letzten Jahren immer häufiger praktizieren. Nationale Gelder einnehmen, national aber nicht zu versteuern, sondern global sich quasi das Schlupfloch zu suchen, wo man versteuern kann. Es ist ein relativ komplexer Punkt, der aber am Ende den europäischen Steuerzahler Milliarden kostet. Nicht Millionen, sondern Milliarden kostet. Cristiano Ronaldo spielt in einem Land, wo die Arbeitslosigkeit riesig ist. Er kommt aus einem Land, wo es genau der gleiche Punkt ist. In beiden Ländern sind die Arbeitslosigkeit und auch die Jugendarbeitslosigkeit immens. Man könnte von einem Fußballer, der sich ja immer auch als Vorbild – so deklariert sich ja selbst der Fußballer als Vorbild mit seinen Vorbildfunktionen – vielleicht am Ende etwas anderes erwarten, aus diesem Apparat, aus diesem Multimilliardenapparat auch noch das letzte bisschen an Profit und das letzte bisschen an Netto herauszuholen. Wie gesagt, Cristiano Ronaldo ist in unserem Fall derjenige, bei dem es am extremsten sichtbar wurde. Aber wir sehen jetzt durch die Berichterstattung, auch die wir im vergangenen Dezember gemacht haben, wie viele andere Fußballer es gerade trifft, bei denen es zum Teil Hausdurchsuchungen gab, die zum Teil jetzt auch schon angeklagt werden. In Spanien sieht man, dass diese Briefkastenfirmen dort völlig Usus sind. Also dort gibt es nahezu keinen der Spitzenspieler mehr, die nicht auf diese Art und Weise ihre Steuern außer Landes bringen. Aktuell Falcao und Coentrao werden beide angeklagt für Millionensummen. Bei Lionel Messi war es zuvor auch schon so. Man sieht eine Systematik dahinter, auf welche groteske Art und Weise Multimilliarden aus dem Land geschafft werden. Wie gesagt, möglicherweise vollkommen legal.
Das wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen. Das ist für mich so die Frage. Wir kennen diesen ganzen Komplex ja auch, wer sich mit den Panama Papers zum Beispiel mal ausführlicher befasst hat. Da kommen ja gerade auch die British Virgin Islands vor. Und wenn ich das jetzt gerade richtig mich erinnere, dann sitzt sogar die sehr berühmte Anwaltskastelei Mossack von Secker, die da vorkommt. Die sitzt in unmittelbarer Nachbarschaft zu so mancher Briefkastenfirmen, über die ihr schreibt und auf die ihr gestoßen seid.
Ich war ja auf den British Virgin Islands, bin im November da hingeflogen, weil ich mir diese Kanzlei, die rund um Christiano Ronaldo tätig war, angucken wollte. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass die British Virgin Islands wirklich kleine Inselgruppen sind. Tortola, die Hauptinsel, besteht im Endeffekt aus einer Hauptstraße. Ansonsten nur winzige, einstöckige Häuser, die direkt aneinandergebaut sind, bei denen im Erdgeschoss Apotheken irgendwelche Uhrengeschäfte, Brillengeschäfte, Handygeschäfte sind. Und dann im ersten Stock sich diese ganzen Kanzleien aufhalten, die ganzen Geldinstitute aufhalten. Von außen kann man nicht reingucken. Die Rollos sind runtergelassen. Teilweise sind die Fenster völlig verrammelt. Also man kann von außen keinen Blick reinwerfen. Von außen betretbar sind diese Türen auch nur, wenn man einen Sicherheitscode kennt oder eine Sicherheitskarte davor hält. Bei dem Fall von Cristiano Ronaldo ist diese Klitsche, über die dieser dreistellige Millionenbetrag gelaufen ist, direkt oberhalb einer Apotheke, an einer Straßenkreuzung. Wenn man von außen drauf guckt, glaubt man im Leben nicht, was da für Summen entlanglaufen. Rechts daneben ist eine Bruchbude, ein abgerissenes Haus. Links geht es dann, da geht eine Straße zum Flughafen. Ansonsten ist da nicht wirklich was. Man kann dann einmal um die Ecke gehen, geht auf die andere Seite des Gebäudes und noch ungefähr 100 Meter weiter, dann trifft man tatsächlich auf Mossack von Seca. Die haben dort ebenfalls ihr Unternehmen. Auf den British Virgin Islands gibt es 30.000 Einwohner und 600.000 Briefkastenfirmen. Ich glaube, das sagt relativ viel über das Geschäftsmodell dieser Inselgruppen.
Aber gleichzeitig ist für mich ein bisschen die Frage, welche Maßstäbe wollen wir anlegen? Denn es ist zumindest teilweise legal, was da betrieben wird. Es ist nicht komplett illegal, sich eine Briefkastenfirma zuzulegen. Und das ist auch eine gängige Praxis, die wir aus vielen Branchen sehen. Und du sagst zu Recht, Christiano Ronaldo spielt im einen der Länder mit einer der höchsten Jugendarbeitslosigkeiten in Europa und weist auf die entgangenen Steuereinnahmen hin. Und er entzieht sich quasi oder zumindest einen großen Teil seines Vermögens diesem Solidaritätsprinzip, das wir unter Steuern verstehen. Aber mein Gedanke, den ich dabei immer wieder habe und ich weiß nicht, da kann vielleicht Nicole noch so ein bisschen als Korrektiv zwischen uns beiden herhalten. Ehrlich gesagt, bei meiner Steuererklärung bin ich auch dankbar für alle 50 Euro, die ich noch am, wo ich mir dann denke, okay, das ist jetzt noch eine Pauschale, die kann ich noch mitnehmen. Schlimmer wird es jetzt bei mir nicht in der Steuererklärung. Aber dieser Urtrieb, dass man das, was man hat, nicht verlieren möchte, dass man das Gefühl hat, ich habe mir das verdient und das soll mir niemand wegnehmen, den kennt doch jeder von uns.
Ich finde, ein Punkt, den Rafael jetzt da auch schon so kurz gemacht hat, ist ja schon, dass du oder jetzt wir in unseren privaten Steuererklärungen uns in der Regel nicht gleichzeitig auch noch als For the good of the game und als Vorbilder, als auch teilweise moralische Instanzen gerieren. Und das finde ich ist natürlich schon, da sind wir was anderes als der Fußball. Also als Verein oder Organisation und auch als einstelnde Spieler. Ich meine, da ist halt die Frage, ob diese Vorbildfunktion, also diese große gesellschaftliche Aufladung und diese auch politische Aufladung von Fußball und von Fußballern, an der wir dann wiederum auch teilweise mitarbeiten, ob man die nicht auch hinterfragen muss, auch nochmal anders und stärker im Licht, unter anderem von Football Leaks. Aber erstmal ist sie halt da und das existiert ja nebeneinander. Und das finde ich tatsächlich auch nochmal jenseits von dem, was ist da legal und was ist vielleicht so halblegal und was ist definitiv illegal, nochmal eine Frage oder dieser große Widerspruch, den es da gibt. Und das fand ich jetzt bei euch im Buch sehr schön. Da hatte ich den Eindruck, dass dieser Aspekt nochmal stärker auch rauskommt durch die Geschichten über den John, also der ja diesen Widerspruch irgendwie selbst ja auch total verkörpert. Wo ihr beschreibt, wie er sich dann total freut, als Portugal Europameister wird und irgendwie einfach ein wahnsinniger Fußballfan ist und man denkt, ey, wie kann das sein? Und zwar nicht Fan von irgendwie einem Kreisligisten ums Eck, sondern eben von genau dem großen Fußball, über den er wirklich viele Dinge weiß. Also da, das finde ich, das fand ich jetzt einfach als so das Human Interest in dieser Geschichte und das aber gleichzeitig ja was ist, womit man sich auch tatsächlich identifizieren kann, weil das natürlich ein Widerspruch ist, den ja die meisten von uns, denke ich, die Fußballfans sind und aber auch gleichzeitig irgendwie halt sich auch für mehr noch interessieren als wie ist in einem Spiel ausgegangen, einfach auch dauernd mit sich tragen. Also das fand ich nochmal, das fand ich jetzt nochmal im Buch, das ist mir sehr aufgefallen, das fand ich, hatte ich nochmal einen wichtigen Aspekt tatsächlich auch für die Rezeption und ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich auch letztlich die Frage, die sich jetzt, was sich einfach in den nächsten Jahren auch irgendwie vielleicht entscheiden wird oder auch nicht, also die Dinge, die halt nicht irgendwelche Ermittlungsbehörden, die nicht Justiz, Staatsanwaltschaft, FBI, womöglich, also auf diesen Ebenen entschieden wird, sondern die auch eben in genau dieses, wie lange trägt man diesen Widerspruch mit?
Ja, also ich würde ganz gerne, bevor ich nochmal auf Max eingehe und mich gleich darüber aufrege, möchte ich dich noch eine Anekdote erzählen, weil ich damals ziemlich sprachlos war, als mir John am Ende eines unserer Treffen auf einmal gestand, dass er, Ich glaube, dass er, dass sein Lieblingsfußballer Cristiano Ronaldo ist. Wir ahnten, was da jetzt schon auf uns zukommt und welche Dokumente uns vorliegen. Diese Hybris in sich selbst, auf der einen Seite sich als junger Mensch unfassbar darüber zu freuen, wie Cristiano Ronaldo Fußball spielt, wie seine Mannschaft Fußball spielt, wie Portugal Fußball spielt und auf der anderen Seite das Verständnis dafür zu haben, dass das, was da gerade passiert, eine Zerreißprobe für die gesamte Gesellschaft ist. Das, was du nämlich jetzt vorhin gesagt hast, dass jeder von uns versucht, bei seiner Steuererklärung vielleicht ein paar Euro zu maximieren oder versucht, am besten davon zu kommen, ist aus meiner Sicht kaum zu vergleichen mit dem, was uns hier vorliegt. Wir bewegen uns in Europa in einem ständigen, in einer ständigen Zerreißprobe zwischen Subventionierung unterschiedlicher Staaten mit unseren Steuergeldern, weil diese Staaten kurz vor dem Kollaps sind. Und auf der anderen Seite sehen wir, wie genau aus diesen Ländern Superreiche ihre Steuern eben nicht zurückentrichten und nicht zurückgeben, sondern durch Tricks, durch Modelle, durch Optimierungsansätze außer Landes schaffen, um dann am, ja, den maximalen Gewinn daraus zu erzielen. Also gerade für uns junge Menschen, deren Steuersätze steigen und steigen und die am Ende genau vor diesen Fragen stehen, warum muss ich eigentlich das ganze Geld abgeben und warum müssen das andere nicht, bzw. wenn unsere Gelder an den Staat zurückgehen, werden damit nicht mit einem Schlag Ex-Krankenhäuser, Schulen oder Kindergärten saniert. Bei einem einzelnen Superreichen ist das natürlich genau der Fall. Wenn ich 150 oder 200 Millionen Euro aus der Landesebene bekomme und die Europa verloren gehen, weil sie hier nicht versteuert werden können, ist das schon ein Unterschied als wenn Max 50 Euro in seinem Portemonnaie am Ende hat. Ich möchte damit nur zum Ausdruck bringen, dass selbst wenn wir nicht bewerten können, ob es legal oder illegal ist, muss hier die Frage aufgeworfen werden, ob das der richtige Weg für ein gemeinsames Europa ist, ob das der richtige Weg für ein Kontinent ist, der sowieso vor einer Zerreichsprobe steht. Dass wir mit diesen Modellen und mit diesen Schlupflöchern superreichen, die Möglichkeiten, auch die Macht geben, immer reicher zu werden und gleichzeitig aber die vollen Steuersätze bei dem Rest der Gesellschaft heranziehen. Also wenn wir über demografische Pyramiden sprechen, über Gelder, die einer Gesellschaft zurückfließen müssen, damit diese Gesellschaft weiterhin gesellschaftsfähig ist, gleichzeitig aber mit den Schultern zu zucken, wenn Multimilliarden von Fußballern, von Großunternehmen außer Landes geschafft werden, dann dürfen wir uns, glaube ich, als Gesellschaft über relativ wenig wundern, weil dann ist das genau der Weg, den wir uns jetzt im Moment hineinbewegen, der dazu führen wird, dass es insbesondere jungen Menschen in Zukunft nicht zwingend einfacher wird. Und für sie nicht einfacher wird.
Da gebe ich dir auch recht, ich habe auch eher eine Emotion gespiegelt, denn das kommt so ein bisschen aus der Erfahrung, die ich aus der Reaktion oder auch ausbleibenden Reaktion auf die erste Veröffentlichungswelle mit den Football Leaks gemacht habe. Da habe ich lange drüber nachgedacht, warum hat das eigentlich nicht zu einem größeren Aufschrei geführt. Und meine Theorie dazu ist, dass dieses Gefühl – es geht jetzt nicht um die Summe, natürlich ist ein Unterschied, ob ich irgendwie 50 Euro versuche rauszuschlagen oder Cristiano Ronaldo 50 Millionen Euro. Das ist natürlich ein Unterschied, aber das Gefühl ist, glaube ich, ein sehr ähnliches. Und ich glaube, dass jeder sich damit identifizieren kann, zumindest in dem nicht jeder im gleichen Maße, denn jeder hat andere moralische Ansprüche. Und ich würde was vermuten, die moralischen Ansprüche von uns dreien hier in diesem Gespräch sind wahrscheinlich auch sehr ähnlich und sehr hoch. Und dennoch leg 10 Euro auf einen Tisch in einem Restaurant und geh aus dem Laden und guck von zehn Leuten, die es sehen und dich noch rauslaufen sehen, wie viele davon werden dich zurückrufen und werden dir sagen, hier sie haben Geld vergessen und wie viele stecken es davon ein. Also verstehst du, was ich meine? Ich wollte so ein bisschen spiegeln, warum ich glaube, dass am Tag der Veröffentlichung war der Klassikoo und ein spanisches Fernsehteam befragt Fans des FC Barcelona und von Real Madrid, was sie davon halten, was Cristiano Ronaldo macht, um Steuern zu vermeiden. Und die überwiegende Mehrheit sagt, ja, ist halt so, dass wenn es die Möglichkeit gibt oder ja macht er doch schlau oder er ist ein so grandioser Fußballer, er hat sich das verdient, der Aufschrei ist doch ausgeblieben.
Nur für das Gegengewicht beim Klassikogapis aber auch eine nicht geringe Fan-Gruppierung, die gesungen hat, Cristiano, zahl deine Steuern. Also das war auch im Stadion laut stark vernehmbar. Ich glaube, Steuerthemen werden erst dann deutlich, wenn man sie auf den jeweiligen Menschen selbst herunterbricht. Ich versuche bei Podiumsdiskussionen immer die Frage zu stellen, wer denn Cristiano Ronaldo bezahlt? Wer bezahlt sein Gehalt? Wer bezahlt seine Image Rights? Wer bezahlt das Gehalt und die Image Rights von hunderten anderen Fußballern? Wenn man dann zu der Antwort kommt, dass wir alle das tun, und wenn man auch in Spanien zu der Antwort kommt, dass das alle tun, und wenn man dann eben die nächste Frage aufwirft und sagt, aus dem jeweiligen Land gehen dann genau diese Steuern weg, für die man selbst gearbeitet hat und die für dieses Land notwendig sind, um beispielsweise eine Schule aufrecht zu erhalten, ein Krankenhaus aufrecht zu erhalten, einen Kindergarten aufrecht zu erhalten, dann wird da oft ein Schuh draus, dass man direkt erklärt diese 150, diese 200 Millionen, das ist nicht das Geld von Cristiano Ronaldo, sondern das ist das Geld, was er durch euch alle Und das ist das, was euch am Ende ja auch fehlen wird, weil es nicht wieder zurückkommt. So funktioniert unsere demokratische Gesellschaft, so funktioniert das westliche Demokratie-Modell. Und wenn man dann den nächsten Schritt geht und sagt, wenn Spanien, Portugal, alles Länder, denen es finanziell wirklich sehr, sehr schlecht geht, wenn die irgendwann mal in eine Position kommen sollten, wie es bei Griechenland zuletzt war, dann ist auch einmal die direkte, eigene Bedrohung von Menschen da. Weil dann wird klar, wir müssen einen Rettungsschirm machen, wir müssen Gelder bezahlen. Das tut weh, weil man dann selbst mitbekommt, dass das Gelder aus dem eigenen Etat der Bundesregierung sind. Ab dem Moment fängt der Aufschrei an. Ich finde, wir als investigative Journalisten versuchen, dazu beizutragen, dass dieser Aufschrei nicht erst am Ende der Kette passiert, sondern dass wir jetzt schon aufzeigen, wo eigentlich die Probleme liegen. Wo beginnt der erste Punkt, der für einen Aufschrei notwendig wäre? Das ist der, dass wir Superreichen in unserer Gesellschaft immer mehr ermöglichen, diese Gelder zu maximieren und zwar zu maximieren auf unsere Kosten.
Aber hast du da nicht das Gefühl, das wäre meine Frage, ich würde dir inhaltlich totale Zustimmung. Ich habe immer den Eindruck, dass der Fußball in der Wahrnehmung aber eben ganz oft eben tatsächlich nicht Teil von eben dem nationalen Steuersystem und irgendwie bestimmten genau auch diesen und jenen Regeln unterworfen ist, sondern dass es immer so scheint, als würde der Fußball sich, also eben der große Fußball, in seiner eigenen Welt abspielen und der Fußball tut natürlich auch viel dazu, um diesen Eindruck irgendwie auch herzustellen. Deswegen wäre meine Frage, wer sind so die Reaktionen, die ihr bekommen habt, würdest du sagen, sind die so, dass es diesen Link wirklich gibt, sei es jetzt Ronaldo, Özil, wer auch immer, dass es dann diesen Link zu ja genau, deswegen bräuchte es auch, müssen wir gucken, wie gehen wir mit reichen Menschen in unserer Gesellschaft steuerlich irgendwie um? Also, dass es diesen Transfer findet, der dann statt oder gibt es nicht vielmehr halt eben diese Schulterzucken so ein bisschen, na Fußball wissen wir eh, da geht es nur noch ums Geld so platt?
Diesen Ansatz, mich in den Kopf des Lesers oder des Zuhörers zu bewegen, der fällt mir ziemlich schwer, weil ich einfach glaube, dass man da nicht einen allgemeinen Tenor bekommen würde. Ich habe vor 2009, 2008, 2009, habe ich über Wettbetrug geschrieben, da habe ich gedacht, dass ich gesteinigt werde von Fußballfans, weil sie mir, weil sie das niemals geglaubt haben, dass so etwas möglich ist, dass ihre Helden mit Absichten Elfmeter verursachen oder Ballnehmens Torschießen. Ich habe über das Sommermärchen, um jetzt so ein Beispiel zu nennen, geschrieben und habe damals eine Mail von einem Leser bekommen, der gesagt hat, der geschrieben hat, das regt euch eigentlich so auf, das ist so ein 6, 7 Millionen, das ist doch ein super Schnapper für eine Weltmeisterschaft. Ein günstiger kann man so ein Ding doch gar nicht kriegen. Ihr vom Spiegel legt euch mal wieder schlafen. Diese Emotionalisierung des Sports, die Emotionalisierung dieser Branche sind ja auch dafür verantwortlich, dass sie sich so enthemmen konnte und dass sie so wachsen konnte, wie sie das in den vergangenen Jahren getan hat. Ich vergleiche das mal so ein bisschen mit der katholischen Kirche, die auch über Jahrzehnte, Jahrhunderte, wie auch immer, tun und lassen konnte, was sie wollte, weil sie das einzige Gemeinschaftskit einer Gesellschaft war, weil jeder dorthin gegangen ist, es ein gemeinsames Gefühl gab, es auch schick war, in die Kirche zu gehen, bis man dann festgestellt hat, wie viele dunkle Seiten die katholische Kirche dann am Ende auch hatte, die dann peu a peu aufgekommen sind. Beim Fußball sehe ich eine ganz ähnliche Bewegung, dass viele Menschen die Probleme gar nicht sehen wollen, weil sie schlicht und ergreifend auch sagen, es gibt genug Probleme auf dieser Welt, da muss ich mich nicht noch den Bereich kaputt machen lassen, der mir vielleicht meine vier Stunden oder fünf Stunden angenehme Zeit in der Woche beschafft. Und da gehen auch alle meine Freunde hin und ich fühle mich im Stadion wohl oder vom Fernseher wohl. Ich will über diese ganzen Machenschaften gar nicht nachdenken. Das ist ein Ansatz, den kann jeder so fahren, wenn er ihn für richtig hält. Ich persönlich glaube, dass wir als – das ist unsere Verantwortung als Journalisten – genau auf diese Verfehlung einer Branche hinzuweisen und dem Leser selbst zu überlassen, was er daraus macht. Wenn er am Ende sagt, es ist mir egal und ich fühle mich wohl damit, dass ich Ticketpreise von 100 Euro aufwärts zahle oder dass ich Krikus kaufe, die so teuer sind, dass man damit sonst etwas finanzieren könnte und am Ende haut dieses Geld hier ab und wird hier legal, illegal, wie auch immer, nicht zurückgeführt in die Gesellschaft, dann ist das eine Entscheidung, die ich akzeptiere, die jeder hier akzeptiert aus unserem Team. Aber zumindest wollen wir die Möglichkeit geben, dass der Mensch da draußen darüber nachdenkt.
Ihr habt auch in einer Region des Fußballs mit der Taschenlampe geleuchtet, mit der durch Football Leaks betriebenen Taschenlampe, die bisher sehr im Verborgenen lag, nämlich die ganze Welt der Berater, der Berater Honorare und auch des ganzen Themenkomplexes Third-Party-Ownership, was bedeutet, dass ich mir die Rechte an Transfers von Spielern sichern konnte bis zum Mai 2015. Das ist ein sehr dubioses Feld. Hier bewegen wir uns auch in Strukturen, die oft nicht anders als mit mafiösen Strukturen zu vergleichen sind. Und ich glaube, das ist auch der Bereich der Football Leaks, der einfacher zu fassen ist, weil man als einfacher Fußballfan das sehr leicht nachvollziehen kann, dass sich hier die Summen nicht mehr in einer direkten Korrelation zur Leistung stehen müssen. Also wenn ich mehrere Millionen Euro einfach nur dafür bekomme, dass jemand nicht den Verein wechselt. Ich habe nichts dafür getan. Oder wenn ich Wertsteigerungen habe innerhalb von 12 Monaten von mehreren hundert Prozent, dann bewegen wir uns eben in einer kapitalistischen Welt, wo es leicht fällt zu sagen, das kann so nicht richtig sein. Da ist etwas aus den Fugen geraten. Kannst du uns mal so schwer es ist, grob erklären, was sind so die wichtigsten Mechanismen, die ihr mit Football Leaks jetzt erstmal belegen konntet, von dem man vorher immer nur so gehört hatte, vielleicht auch wieder an einem Beispiel?
Also lustigerweise, um noch mal grundsätzlich zu werden, lustigerweise bekommen wir das aber auch rückgespiegelt, dass es anscheinend Fußballfans wahnsinnig leicht fällt, über Spielerberater zu schimpfen, aber eher schwer fällt, über ihre Helden und ihre Lieblingsvereine sich aufzuregen. Obwohl, eigentlich gibt es in ihren Geschäftspraktiken kaum einen Unterschied. Die Art der Geschäfte läuft auf völlig ähnliche Art und Weise ab.
Aber die Spielerberater schießen dich halt nicht zur Meisterschaft.
Genau, und das ist die Emotionalität, die ich meine, die dann am Ende vielleicht auch dazu führt, dass der klare Blick auf die Sachverhalte getrübt wird und einfach nicht da ist, weil eben am Ende vielleicht doch der BVB das DFB-Pokalfinale gewinnt und allen anderen dann wurscht es, was so drumherum passiert ist. Also um aber konkret nochmal auf die Spielerberater einzugehen, das muss man unterscheiden. Ich glaube, dass Spielerberater im heutigen Markt wichtig sind, weil sie Spielern helfen, vom Verein nicht komplett über die Leisten gezogen zu werden und nicht ausgenommen zu werden, insbesondere jungen Spielern. Es gibt auch ein paar gute Berater, die tauchen in unseren Büchern eher nicht auf, sondern wir sehen diejenigen, die teilweise ihre Branche sehr monopolisiert haben, die mittlerweile einen Stellenwert haben, der höher ist als der von einzelnen Vereinen. Das Beispiel, das sie in den vergangenen Wochen aus unserem Buch vielleicht den meisten Rauch verursacht hat und die meisten Schlagzeilen verursacht hat, sind die 49 Millionen, das 49 Millionen Honorar von Mino Raiola, das er bekommen hat für den 105 Millionen Euro Weltrekord-Transfer von Paul Pogba von Juventus Turin zu Manchester United. Das muss man sich so vorstellen, dass Raiola mit einem Transfer nahezu 50 Millionen macht. Das ist ein höherer Jahresumsatz als von vielen Zweitligisten oder Mannschaften, die in den ersten Ligen im unteren Drittel spielen. Das macht er mit einem einzelnen Transfer. Ich glaube, dass solche Summen, die Absurditäten solcher Summen, solche Exzesse, die von Beratern dann auch gemacht werden, dass die am ehesten zum Unverständnis oder für Unverständnis da draußen auch bei den normalen Leuten sorgen, weil die nicht verstehen, was diese Berater dafür tun. Dass sie nicht verstehen, dass alles das, was ich vorhin gesagt habe, auch über die Steuermodelle und auch über die Strukturen von Offshore und von Grundkapitalisierung eines Marktes, das sind ja nur die Grundelemente, die Auswüchse davon sind dann das, was das Beraterwesen zum Beispiel zeigt oder das, was das Sponsoring wiedergibt oder Investorenmodelle, die entstehen. Das sind im Prinzip die Auswüchse einer Branche, die sich nur noch und ausschließlich am Geld orientiert. Sie produziert dann genau solche Phänomene. Jorge Mendez, der Berater von Cristiano Ronaldo, der auch mal in einem Transfer-Sommer 200 Millionen macht oder wie gesagt, Mino Raiola mit seinen Riesendeals. Auch Volker Struth, der Berater von Toni Kroos, der mit einer Vertragsverlängerung am Ende bei 5 Millionen landet oder der Berater Roger Wittmann, der die Vertragsverlängerung mit dem 19-jährigen Julian Draxler macht und am Ende bei 1, 5 Jahre wartet und dann an Julian Draxlers Wechsel zum VfW Wolfsburg 7 Millionen verdient. Wenn man das alles liest, fragt man sich natürlich, wo sich der Wettbewerb hin bewegt. Unter welchen Gesichtspunkten geben dann Berater Ratschläge, wohin ein Spieler geht oder wann er wechselt, welche Faktoren üben Investoren auf einen Spieler aus, der seinen Marktwert gesteigert hat, bevor er wechselt? Wechselt dieser Spieler dann zudem für ihn in der Karriere richtigen Verein? Wechselt bleibt er bei dem Verein, der ihm gerade die besten Möglichkeiten für eine sportliche Entwicklung gibt, oder werden diese Spieler dann z.T. mit extremem Druck wegtransferiert, damit die Rendite an dem Spieler riesig wird? Ich kann das konkrete Beispiel Saul Niguez, ein wunderbarer Techniker, Mittelfeldspieler von Atletico Madrid, der jetzt auch im Halbfinale-Rückspiel zwischen Atletico und Real das Kopfballtor gemacht hat. Man freut sich mit diesem Spieler, weil er einfach wundervoll im Fußball spielt. Wenn wir in unsere Daten gucken und wir beschreiben in unserem Buch ein ganzes Kapitel über ihn und Atletico, stellen wir fest, dass dieser Spieler am Ende nur zu 60% Atletico gehört. Er gehört zu 40% fremden Investoren, die Anteile an ihm gekauft haben, als er am Anfang seiner Karriere war und jetzt nichts anderes tun, als darauf zu warten, dass ihre Aktie – weil nichts anderes ist er für sie – steigt und steigt und steigt und irgendwann den Punkt sehen, an dem sie sagen, okay, jetzt machen wir einen Cut, du wechselst und wir bekommen unsere Rendite, wir bekommen unsere Möglichkeiten an dir zu verdienen. Im Fall von Saul Niguez, er hat eine Ablösesumme, die am Ende dazu, wenn er für diese Ablösesumme wechselt, dazu führt, dass die Investoren mit der Einlage, die sie am Anfang hatten, eine Rendite von 1000 Prozent machen. Mir muss jemand zeigen, in welchem anderen Bereich der Gesellschaft wir uns bewegen, wo man solche Renditen heutzutage machen kann, abgesehen vom Kokain- und Menschenhandel.
Das ist auch ein sehr interessanter Punkt im Buch, dass ihr aufzeigen könnt, in welche Abhängigkeiten sich gerade auch Vereine gegenüber solchen Agenturen, die mehrere Spieler haben, oder auch Spielerberatern geben. Jetzt auch in dem von dir angesprochenen Beispiel gibt es kein Szenario, in dem dieses Investment einen Verlust in sich hat. Das heißt, es ist quasi risikoneutral. Denn selbst wenn er Sportinvalide werden würde, müsste Atletico Summen überweisen. Das habt ihr auch in anderen Beispielen noch gezeigt. Hier sind ja zwei Dinge zeitlich zueinander gekommen. Das eine ist, dass wir eine ganze Reihe von europäischen Fußballvereinen haben, die sich finanziell irgendwann mal verhoben haben und deshalb klamm waren und auf der Suche nach schnellem Geld. Und auf der anderen Seite drängt jetzt ganz viel Geld aus den unterschiedlichsten Quellen. Und da schreibt ihr ja auch ausführlich drüber auch durchaus Quellen, wo man sich sehr sicher sein kann, dass es nicht immer das weißeste und sauberste Geld ist, das man jeweils in seinem Leben gesehen hat. Dieses Geld drängt jetzt in den Fußballbereich rein, der einfach Renditen abwirft, derzeit, die man nirgendwo sonst gerade haben kann. Wie erklärst du dir es denn, dass weder Verbände noch Vereine noch die darüber residierenden Dachverbände, jetzt konkret zum Beispiel die FIFA, es geschafft haben, das zu verhindern, dass dieses in den Fußball hineindringende Geld, das ist natürlich willkommen, aber das ist ja vollkommen außer Kontrolle geraten, in welche Abhängigkeiten sich da die Vereine zum Beispiel begeben?
Also ich glaube, das Grundstichwort ist Machtlosigkeit und zwar völlige Machtlosigkeit von Verbänden und von Dachorganisationen, dieser ganzen Geschichte in irgendeiner Form Herr zu werden. Die FIFA hat beispielsweise das Beraterreglement, ich glaube, das ist jetzt zwei Jahre her, hat sie aufgegeben. Also sie hat das an die Nationalverbände zurückdelegiert und hat gesagt, okay, ihr wählt aus, unter welchen Gesichtspunkten jemand ein Berater sein kann oder nicht sein darf. Und ich glaube, man verrät nicht zu viel, wenn man sagt, jeder kann heute Berater werden. Du brauchst eine gewisse Grundeinlage, wenn du dich finanziell halbwegs gut aufstellst, ist es problemlos möglich, da reinzukommen. Und noch einfacher ist es für Investoren. Sind wir nochmal ehrlich, ich kenne keinen Verein, der tatsächlich hinterfragt, woher das Geld am Ende kommt, das er erhält. Also es ist so ähnlich wie die Bankenbranche Ende der Nuller Jahre, die schlicht und ergreifend eigentlich keinerlei Due-Diligence oder Compliance-Bestimmungen hatte, die halbwegs gegriffen haben. So ist es doch hier im Fußball auch. Wenn eine Mannschaft wie Twente Enschede oder wie Atletico dem finanziellen Kollaps entgegensteuern, weil sie so hohe Schulden haben, weil sie sich mit Spielern verhoben haben, weil sie zu lange nicht europäisch gespielt haben, dann begeben sie sich in die erstbesten Hände von Investoren und verkaufen ihre Identität, verkaufen ihre Jugendspieler oder Anteile an ihren Jugendspielern, um weiterhin Geld zu haben, um neue Spieler zu kaufen, um wettbewerbsfähig zu sein. Wir beschreiben im Buch über ein sehr langes Kapitel die Firma Doyens Sports, die wirklich nichts anderes gemacht hat als eine Art Knebelverträge mit den jeweiligen Vereinen, bei denen sie dann auch mit fünf, sechs, sieben Spielern eingestiegen, also Anteile von Spielern eingekauft hat und am Ende nichts anderes getan hat als eine gewisse Macht über diesen Verein zu haben, weil sie durch die Nebenklauseln im Endeffekt diejenigen waren, die auch darauf einwirken konnten, wann ein Spieler verkauft wird. Sie mussten vom Verein informiert werden über die Angebote und wenn der Verein beispielsweise das Angebot eines dritten Clubs abgelehnt hat, dann musste dieser Verein eine Entschädigungszahlung an den Investoren machen. So eine logische Folgerung. Du bist als Verein knapp bei Kasse, bekommst ein Angebot von deinem dritten Club für deinen Spieler, willst den Spieler nicht verkaufen, weil du wettbewerbsfähig bleiben musst, kannst aber auch gleichzeitig das Geld nicht ablehnen, weil du dann weder die Einnahme der Ablöses und gleichzeitig auch noch den Investor auszahlen musst. Was machst du also? Du verkaufst deinen Spieler. Das heißt, der Investor greift direkt in die Kaderplanung ein, greift direkt in die Gestaltung der Mannschaft ein, also ein externer Faktor, der die Aufstellung bedingt. Und diese Ausuferung der Investorenmodelle, die spürt man dann, wenn solche Dinge passieren, die jetzt aktuell es gibt – vor ein paar Wochen sind ja die ersten Fälle publik geworden – ein irischer Verein, ein spanischer Verein, bei dem auf einmal die Polizei eingeritten ist, weil festgestellt wurde, dass diese Vereine vollkommen ausgehöhlt wurden, und zwar von chinesischen Investoren, von italienischen Investoren, die nicht wirklich den sportlichen Erfolg im Auge hatten, sondern die haben Anteile an den Vereinen gekauft, haben dann gleichzeitig ihre eigenen Spieler in diese Vereine gebracht, haben diese Vereine immer wieder Spiele verlieren lassen und haben gleichzeitig auf diese Niederlagen auf den Wettmarkt gesetzt. So entstehen auch Renditen, wenn man sich in Abhängigkeiten zu Investoren begibt.
Sind dir oder euch bei euren Recherchen irgendwelche Quellen des Widerstandes oder irgendwelche – das Wort Reform mag man nach diesen FIFA-Reformen immer auch gar nicht mehr in den Mund nehmen. Aber ich finde, dass es da irgendwo Institutionen gibt, die sagen, machen wir jetzt mal anders oder so nicht. Oder wir leiden auch darunter, weil das beschreibt ihr ja auch. Du hast das ja auch noch mal beschrieben. Die Vereine und auch Spieler werden ja auch selbst zu Opfern dieses Systems. Sie sind teilweise Profiteure, aber es geht ja auch nicht immer gut. Siehst du da innerhalb der Fußballbranche irgendwelche Bewegungen? Oder muss das wirklich von außen kommen, von der Politik oder von der Justiz?
Also wir haben aus der Fußballbranche selbst von immer noch aktiven Fußballern nahezu nur Schweigen geerntet. Auch auf Anfragen nur Schweigen geerntet. Wir haben im Zuge der ersten Football Leaks Berichterstattung im Dezember ein Interview mit Gianni Infantino geführt. Das war für mich ein gerade Beispiel, wie ein Mensch sich auf Eis bewegt und unter seinen Sohlen nur Butter hat. Also dieser Gianni Infantino, der wackelte, der schlitterte, der versuchte sich herauszuwinden mit Phrasen und Worthülsen und sagte in wirklich blumigsten Worten immer wieder, wir werden uns das genau angucken, wir werden uns überlegen, wie wir damit umgehen, wir werden. Dass kritisch beurteilen passiert ist, genau nichts. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass irgendwas aus der Branche passiert, dass diese Branche sich in irgendeiner Form selbst reglementiert. Das wäre auch ziemlich dumm, weil alle an dieser Branche wahnsinnig viel verdienen und jeder, der – auch wenn es nur der kleinste Berater ist – jeder, der daran verdient, hat kein Interesse daran, die Hand, die ihn füttert, zu beißen. Von denjenigen, von denen wir einen irren Zuspruch und auch Anfragen erhalten haben, waren Steuerbehörden. Steuerfahnen. Unsere Quelle, John, unser Whistleblower, ist direkt in den ersten Tagen der Veröffentlichung über die Homepage bombardiert worden von Steuerbehörden, die sich bei ihnen gemeldet haben, die um Auskunft erbeten haben, die teilweise mitgeteilt haben, dass sie seit Jahren schon hinter bestimmten Konstrukten her sind, die ihre Verzweiflung ausgedrückt haben, wie sie an Briefkastenfirmen scheitern, wie sie an Auskunftsgesuchen in der Karibik oder im Nahen Osten, in China, wie sie daran einfach scheitern, wie sie dort nicht weiterkommen. Da haben wir schon gemerkt, wie viel Druck eigentlich auf dem Kessel ist und wie viele Steuerfahnder die Probleme sehr deutlich sehen, aber überhaupt kein Werkzeug haben in unserer aktuellen Gesellschaft, diesen Machenschaften irgendwie auf die Spur zu kommen. Die sind schlicht und ergreifend verzweifelt.
Das ist eigentlich auch eine schöne Geschichte. Unerkannte Helden, die Steuerbehörden.
Die sehen, dass sie am Ende wieder ausgetrickst werden, egal was sie machen. Wir sehen ja auch an den Daten, es gibt einen niederländischen, argentinischen Spielerberaterring, der die ganzen Geschäfte hier in Europa macht, teilweise mit echten Topstars. Die Topstars werden hier beraten. Und diese Spielerberater schalten Strohmänner dazwischen, die für sie dann die Verträge mit den Spielern abschließen und die Honorare werden dann an diese Strohmänner weitergeleitet. Diese Strohmänner behalten von diesen Honoraren dann 2000, 2500 Euro, wie auch immer, und leiten den Millionenbetrag weiter an eine Firma auf den British Virgin Islands. Das ist dann die Firma, für die sie honorarmäßig gearbeitet haben, der Geldfluss geht raus. Wo werden dann diese Millionen versteuert? Natürlich auf den British Virgin Islands, mit 0 Prozent. Das haben wir uns sehr gut angeguckt, weil wir dann auch am Ende jemanden gefunden haben, beziehungsweise unsere Partner von NRC Handelsblatt haben, unsere EIC-Partner von NRC Handelsblatt in Holland, haben diese Person gefunden. Das beschreiben wir auch im Buch. Das ist ein Poet, ein Dichter. Er schreibt Poesie. Er hatte mal zwei schlechte Jahre. Seine Bücher sind nicht gut verkauft worden in den Niederlanden. Wie auch immer ist er in diesen niederländisch- argentinischen Spielerberaterring hineingestolpert über einen Freund, der gesagt hat, hey, das ist total schnell verdientes Geld und du kriegst dann keine Probleme. Das ist schon sehr lustig und blumig, wie er beschreibt, wie dann irgendjemand ihn mit einem Auto abholt. Er bekommt einen Aktenkoffer in die Hand, in dem zig Dokumente drin liegen. Er sieht diese Dokumente aber erst Stunden später, weil er selbst darf diesen Koffer gar nicht aufmachen, sondern er wird zu irgendeinem Rollfeld gebracht an einem Flughafen, wo ein Privatflugzeug landet. Es steigt jemand aus, der Koffer wird aufgemacht. Die Dokumente werden ausgetauscht, die er unterschrieben hat. Er muss sie dann einmal unterschreiben in seinem Namen, dass er dieses Honorar erhalten hat. Dann werden diese Dokumente gegen andere Dokumente ausgetauscht. Er macht den Koffer wieder zu und fährt wieder nach Hause. Das ist Mafiastoff. Auf diese Art und Weise laufen Geschäfte im Fußball ab. Wenn man diesen Menschen gegenüber sitzt, sagt er, ich versteuere hier alles ganz sauber meine zweieinhalbtausend Euro. Ich bin auf der sicheren Seite. Wir stehen vor diesem Gebäude, bei dem wir wissen, hier läuft die Kohle aus Europa drüber, über einen Ring, der sich über verschlüsselte Kanäle unterhält, der über verschlüsselte Kanäle genau dieses System erfunden hat und über dieses System kooperiert. Das macht etwas mit einem, das ist ein ungutes Gefühl und wenn man dann feststellt, wenn Steuerveranstalter dem ganzen auf die Schliche kommen, dann passiert Folgendes. Diese Firma wird einfach abgewickelt, sie wird einfach dicht gemacht, die ganze Kohle aus dieser Firma wird rausgeholt, sie wird nach Hongkong überwiesen oder nach Dubai. Das ist jetzt rein hypothetisch. Ich müsste jetzt Buch gucken, um genau zu sagen, wohin das Geld überwiesen wurde. Auf jeden Fall wird diese Firma platt gemacht, der Strohmann verschwindet und der dahinter liegende Strohmann verschwindet auch. Danach geht das Geld wieder auf Reisen und der Steuerfahnder in Europa darf das nächste Rechtshilfe ersuchen, an ein anderes Land stellen, was dann vielleicht wieder zwei oder drei Jahre dauert. Solange diese Jungs keine Fehler machen, solange sie genau solche Experten haben, die dieses Geld durch die ganze Welt schießen, hat ein europäischer Steuerfahnder überhaupt keine Möglichkeit dahinter zu kommen und sich dranzuschauen.
Oder solange man das nicht irgendwie belegen kann, was ja jetzt durch die Football Leaks passiert ist und was ich sehr interessant finde, ist, dass, so wie ihr das im Buch schildert, hinter John stehen ja mehrere Menschen. Es ist nicht klar, wie viele und erst recht weiß man nicht, wer und wo die alle sitzen. Aber es ist ein Netzwerk und noch während ihr den ersten Kontakt hattet, hat dieses Netzwerk immer neue Dokumente bekommen aus allen verschiedenen Richtungen. Am Anfang konzentrierte sich das sehr auf Portugal und Spanien und viele Fälle hat mit Spielern zu tun, die zumindest mal in Spanien gespielt haben. Aber dieser Datenschatz, wie du ihn nennst, ist immer weiter angewachsen. Wird denn da jetzt dann noch mehr kommen in Zukunft? Denn das hört sich ja so an, als ob wir es hier nicht mit – wir haben zwar einen John, der ja überall immer John heißt – John Doe, das ist ja quasi ein Max-Mustermann. Aber es wirkt so, als ob wir dahinter ein Netzwerk, vielleicht Organisation, etwa eine Gruppe von Menschen hätte, die jetzt aktiv gerade weitere Dokumente sammelt. Meistens wird es noch weitere Leaks geben.
Also ohne das Ende des Buches zu spoilern, das möchte ich nicht, kann ich glaube ich sagen, dass wir weiterhin weiteres Material bekommen, dass wir auch in den letzten Wochen und Monaten daraus neue Geschichten gemacht haben. Eine der Geschichten sind die Vergewaltigungsvorwürfe, beispielsweise gegen Cristiano Ronaldo, die eine völlig eigene andere Geschichte sind, eben aber auch aus diesem Datenschatz stammen. Wer hinter Football Leaks am Ende steckt oder wer Football Leaks ist, kann ich bis zum Schluss, also bis zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt der Recherche trotz, ich glaube, hundertfacher Nachfragen nicht beantworten. Ich habe bislang mit einer einzigen Person zu tun gehabt, der ich versprochen habe, dass ich sie in der Anonymität lasse. Wer ansonsten an diesem Netzwerk mitarbeitet, kann ich schlicht und ergreifend nicht seriös beantworten. Ich kann von meinem Treffen mit John berichten, wenn ich am Ende von ihm in eine Wohnung geführt werde, die aber eigentlich ein Büroraum ist, wo unterschiedliche Türen geöffnet stehen, beziehungsweise einen Spalt breit offen stehen. Ich sehe diese Menschen dort in den Zimmern, ich sehe sie teilweise in der Küche. Ich weiß nicht, ob es seine Mitbewohner sind, ob es seine Freunde sind, ob es Arbeitskollegen sind. Das verrät er mir nicht. Sie sprechen nicht mit mir. Wir müssen eher wie Geister, die da über die Flure huschen. Das macht das alles auch nicht ganz so einfach für uns, weil man am Ende eine sehr, sehr weiche Quelle – so würden wir als Journalisten das ausdrücken – hat, bei der man keinen Anfang und keinen Ende hat. Man weiß nicht, wie sich das Ganze strukturiert. Man versteht die Organisationskultur dahinter. Was ich, glaube ich, verraten kann, ist, dass John immer wieder sagt, sollte es jemals in Bezug auf ihn zu einer Verhaftung kommen, ist dafür gesorgt, dass dieses Football-Leaks-Modell weiterhin aufrecht erhalten wird. Er hat mir mal eine Art tickende Zeitbombe gezeigt, weil wenn so ein Button in seinem Computer nicht bedient wird, dann beginnt Football Leaks automatisch, die Daten hochzuladen. Es gibt Sicherheitsmechanismen, die die Organisation beziehungsweise die ER getroffen haben, die dazu führen, dass sein Datenkonvolut nicht in Vergessenheit gerät, wenn es ihn mal nicht geben sollte.
Football Leaks hat ja auch über die eigene Intention immer mal wieder Auskunft gegeben, auch im Buch, und das wurde auch vorher schon veröffentlicht, und da schreiben sie, Zitat, unser Antrieb ist es, all denen das Handwerk zu legen, die sich zu Unrecht an dem Volkssport Fußball bereichern. Wir wollen zudem eine neue Ära im Fußball einläuten, die Zeit der Transparenz. Und jetzt hast du ja schon ganz gut beschrieben, Rafael, und das wird auch noch mal eindrucksvoll, und da wird man sehr wütend an dieser Stelle des Buches beschrieben, wie die Verbände und Vereine reagiert haben nach Football Leaks. Spoiler, es ist nicht so, dass wir jetzt eine neue Zeit der Transparenz haben. Stelle ich mir die Frage, Rafael, was kann man da denn jetzt tun? Denn diese Wut, die lässt einen nicht los, wenn man von diesen Summen liest, wenn man das immer mal wieder hat, man im Buch so Momente, wo man sich denkt, ach, der kriegt, hat jetzt nur 400.000 für den Deal bekommen, das ist ja fast wenig. Und dann überlegt man sich, Moment mal, wie viele Jahre müsste ich eigentlich dafür arbeiten? Aber das hatte ich wirklich immer wieder, weil einfach diese Summen so hoch sind. Jetzt ist die Frage, wohin mit meiner Wut, Rafael, was kann ich denn tun? Was kann der Fußballfan tun?
Ich glaube, da überfragst du meine Kompetenzen als Journalist bzw. Das muss jeder für sich selbst beurteilen. Ich glaube, ich würde mich schlicht und ergreifend nur auf das konzentrieren wollen, was wir enthöhnen können bzw. was wir aufzeigen können. Du hast vorhin eine interessante Sache gesagt, wie die Verbände reagiert haben. Für mich ist immer noch das Highlight Karl-Heinz Rummenigge, der sich in einer HCR-Sitzung furchtbar darüber aufregt, dass die Atmosphäre in der Umkleidekabine durch die Football Leaks ein wenig ungemütlich wurde, weil die Spieler sich über die unterschiedlichen Gehälter unterhalten haben.
Das war eine der Stellen, die ich meinte. Da bin ich sehr wütend geworden.
Genau. Da geht es nicht mehr darum, können wir uns eigentlich reflektieren. Ist das noch ein Markt, der irgendwas mit den Menschen zu tun hat, der ihnen bezahlt? Sind wir immer noch auf dem richtigen Weg mit einer Branche, die anscheinend keine – nach oben hin – Bereiche weiterhin für einen offen hält? Müssen wir hier keine Ahnung, einen Salary Cup einrichten? Müssen wir nicht Transparenzhäuser wie ein Clearinghouse für Berater etablieren? Ich habe eigentlich erwartet, dass vielleicht der ein oder andere kluge Geist aus dem Fußball sich mal dazu einlässt. Das habe ich alles nicht gehört, habe mich dann aber versucht, zurückzuerinnern, wie das beispielsweise bei der FIFA zuletzt war. Und da muss man ja ehrlicherweise auch sagen, da reden wir, ich weiß nicht, jetzt auch seit zig Jahren über Reformen und Reformkonzepte, die da entstehen. Die FIFA-Ethikkommission und eigene Ermittlungsbehörden, die im Verband aufgebaut wurden, am Ende hat man gesehen, wer Transparenz in diesen Verband gebracht hat. Ermittlungsgruppen, das FBI, die Schweizer Bundesanwaltschaft, die Frankfurter Staatsanwaltschaft, die Justiz, die dann auf Basis von Hausdurchsuchungen, die auf Basis von Whistleblowern, wie im Fall des FBI, die Kronzeugen bekommen hat, die auf diesen Grundlagen angefangen hat, im Fußball zumindest für einen Übergang in eine neue Zeit zu sorgen. Ob dieser Übergang tatsächlich ein Übergang zur Transparenz sein wird, das wage ich nahezu noch dem, was wir bislang beschrieben haben, ein wenig zu bezweifeln, wenn Uli Hoeneß in Lichtenstein darüber fabuliert, dass man zukünftig womöglich in China Fußball spielt und jeder Chinese einen Lieblingsspieler hat und dann für nur ein Dollar sich ein Stream oder sonst was aufs Handy holt. Bei 300 Fußballbegeisterten sind es mal schlanke 300 Millionen. Da braucht man keinen rechten Künstler mehr zu sein, um zu verstehen, welche neuen Märkte da gerade erschlossen werden sollen und in welche Bereiche der Fußball vordringen soll. Ich neige mittlerweile auch dazu, dass ich kaum noch Grenzen der Absurdität in meinem Kopf generieren kann. Ich habe mir vorgestellt, was eigentlich noch in den kommenden Jahren auf uns zukommen kann, wenn man dann irgendwann mal so auf so ein Spiel zwischen RB Leipzig und RB Salzburg im Champions-League-Finale stößt und das Gefühl hat, vielleicht werden ja noch vier weitere Mannschaften in dieser Champions-League spielen aus der Mateschitz-Imperium. Wer sagte, dass er bei diesen beiden Mannschaften aufhört, wenn es so einfach ist, einen Champions-League-Teilnehmer zu kreieren und sich dann überlegt, wo eigentlich dieses Geld herkommt, was er dann da hinein investiert und dann den nächsten Schritt macht und sagt, Oligarchengeld, Geld aus China, von irgendwelchen Investoren, bei denen man keine Ahnung hat, wie sie ihr Geld eigentlich gemacht haben. Das sind ja alles Faktoren, die irgendwann auf diesen Fußball zukommen werden, wenn er sich so weiter entwickelt, wie er sich entwickelt. Und ich glaube nahezu aus dem Lesen der ganzen Zahlen und dieses Wahnsinns, der auch in Spanien und in England, also in unseren unmittelbaren Konkurrenzländern des deutschen Fußballs gerade entwickelt wird, kann man ja fast davon ausgehen, dass auf uns in den nächsten Monaten eine ziemliche Debatte über die 50 plus 1 Regelung zukommen wird, die schlicht und ergreifend dafür sorgt, dass wir möglicherweise in Deutschland nur über finanzielle Exzesse, aber noch nicht über die ganz extreme Form von Illegalität sprechen, weil wir da eine Bremse noch installiert haben. Aber auch das ist ja nur eine Frage der Zeit, wann auch das in Frage gestellt wird, damit Vereine dann aus ihrer Sicht wettbewerbsfähig bleiben können. Ach herrje, Nicole, das ist ja so eine ganz fiese Partybremse, so komme ich mir hier vor.
Ja, das war jetzt nicht das optimistische Schlusswort.
Ja, also dann kann ich mir ja wirklich nur noch hier den Freizeitkick im Park um die Ecke angucken, weil alles andere ist, das ist ja furchtbar deprimierend. Nicole, kannst du mir sagen, was können wir Fans denn tun? Wir sind doch auch nicht komplett machtlos. Letztlich kommt ja das ganze Geld, oder viel, viel Geld kommt von uns durch Merchandiserlöse, die wir verursachen, dadurch, dass wir ins Stadion gehen, dadurch, dass wir unter anderem durch so tolle Produkte wie den Rasenfunk – ups, sorry – Fußball zu so einer tollen Sache machen, dass man dafür Milliarden an TV-Geldern verlangen kann. Irgendwie steht das ja schon alles im Zusammenhang zum einzelnen Fan, aber irgendwie ist man auch total hilflos.
Ja, also genau, jetzt mit dem – ich habe jetzt die Lösung oder?
Bitte, bitte!
Champions-League-Finale, komm, also DFB-Pokalfinale, eh das allerbeste. Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube, dass schon auch, wie Rafael sagt, dass die, also du musstest eh dann für dich selbst die Wege finden und dann auch, aber natürlich auch teilweise nicht allein. Und das, ich, ich würde schon auch sagen, dass sowas wie Rasenfunk und ganz viele, also da kannst du ja tausend Beispiele finden, was jetzt Fans tun, die eben dann nicht, Entschuldigung, Bayern TV gucken, sondern eben ein eigenes Medium zu machen. Das ist ja auch schon sozusagen in diesem System irgendwie zu bleiben, aber sich darin auch, also darin ein bisschen Sand im Getriebe zu sein.
Ja, aber andererseits steige ich doch so nur die Berichterstattung über die Bundesliga. Ich wollte es jetzt auch gar nicht nur auf den Rasenfunk beziehen, so wichtig nehme ich die Podcast jetzt nicht, aber wenn es die Bundesliga jetzt von einem Tag auf den anderen nicht mehr gäbe, dann hätte ich ja auch ein Problem. Ich versuche ja gerade vom Rasenfunk zu leben.
Ja klar, nein sicher und natürlich, aber ich glaube, das ist einfach, das haben wir ja vorhin auch schon ein bisschen, also ich glaube, das ist halt auch der Widerspruch, der da ist. Also den natürlich sagst du dir, also da machen ja auch Leute schon oder da kannst du ja auch sagen, okay, diese WM in Russland und WM in Katar, das gucke ich mir nicht an. Ich bin nicht Teil von, ich finde, das sind falsche Entscheidungen, es sind Länder, die nicht meiner Vorstellung davon entsprechen, wie eine wenn es Nationen dann schon geben muss, wie die funktionieren sollten und da bin ich jetzt nicht Teil davon. Ich falte jetzt nicht ein, ich teile diese Berichterstattung nicht, ich interessiere mich nicht dafür. Das sind ja Dinge, die man irgendwie tun kann, die sich dann vielleicht auch lächerlich anfühlen oder auch unangenehm. Man fühlt sich komplett uninformiert und isoliert, was weiß ich. Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht wird das auch so aussehen und ich meine, das passiert ja auch. Also es passiert ja durchaus auch, dass sich Leute vom Fußball auch abwenden. Also ich glaube, es passiert einfach noch nicht in einem besonders spürbaren Maße oder es wird derzeit einfach auch noch durch genug anderes aufgefangen. Aber das scheint mir jetzt auch nicht so ausgemacht zu sein, wie das weitergeht. Also ob das Modell Hoeneß, also was Rafael eben noch mal skizziert hat, also ob diese Zukunftsvision dann auch tatsächlich funktioniert, wenn das Fundament, was eben im Moment für den Fußball halt noch hier in Europa irgendwie auch tatsächlich ja teilen, weil zumindest noch in den Stadien gelegt wird, wenn das irgendwie nicht mehr da ist. Also da weiß ich nicht, ob das auch eine naive Hoffnung ist oder eine zynische oder sowieso irgendwas, was auch gar nicht eintreten wird. Also das ist ja auch schwer zu sagen. Aber ich finde schon, dass es diese Bewegung, ob man das jetzt resignativ macht oder auch mit dem, ich spiele jetzt nur noch selbst Fußball oder eben, ich gucke jetzt wirklich, ich gehe dann zum Club um die Ecke.
Vielleicht habe ich jetzt die Lösung dann doch noch gefunden und das passt dann auch perfekt zum Schluss dieser Episode. Ihr konsumiert einfach Bundesliga und all diese Weltmeisterschaften da draußen nicht mehr direkt, sondern nur noch über den Rasenfunk und dadurch, dass ich ja werbefrei bleibe, wodurch, wozu ich mich übrigens wieder ausdrücklich bekräftigt fühle durch Lektüre dieses Buches, könnte euch sicher sein, es guckt dann nur einer und nicht eine Million und ihr hört dann einfach alle den Rasenfunk. Da freue ich mich. Ich zahle meine Steuern. Das wollen wir mit den 50 Euro.
Du machst das mit den 50 Euro auch nicht, ja?
Nein, mache ich nicht. Ich habe einen Steuerberater, dem das wichtigste Ding ist, was ich ihm immer sage, ist, bitte machen sie es einfach nur korrekt. Ich habe keine Lust auf diese ganzen kleineren Tricks, die man da machen kann. Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt auch zu anstrengend. Football Leaks heißt das Buch von Rafael Buschmann und Michael Wulzinger, ist erschienen im Random House Verlag. Ihr solltet es alles lesen. Ich danke ganz, ganz herzlich zum einen Rafael Buschmann bei Twitter at rafanelli, Autor vom Spiegel. Rafael, vielen Dank, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast.
Vielen Dank. Hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Euch alles Gute und bis bald.
Ja, danke. Außerdem vielen herzlichen Dank an Nicole Selmer, stellvertretende Chefredakteurin vom Fußballmagazin Ballesterer, bei Twitter at nick-haha. Vielen Dank, Nicole. Und euch, liebe Hörer, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Kauft euch das Buch Football Leaks. Lest. Es geht um Dietmar Hopp, Dinamo Zagreb, Twente Enschede, Mino Raiola, Halilovic, Gaginovic. Ganz viele Themen, die wir jetzt gar nicht ansprechen konnten. Auch noch einige kritische Themen gegenüber den Machern von Football Leaks. Das alles sollte nur ein kleiner Einblick sein. Und ich glaube auch, es war nicht das letzte Tribünengespräch zum Thema. In diesem Sinne werdet Rasenfunk-Supporter und bis bald. Macht's gut.
Das war das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.